hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American action thriller
film called passenger 57 spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
Charles Reign is a notorious British
terrorist who has orchestrated multiple
bombings assassinations and other
heinous crimes he even tried to kill the
governor but despite his criminal record
he has never been captured the truth is
that Charles is also an escape artist
who uses his power and deception to
elude the authorities in the first scene
we see him in a surgery room with
several doctors surrounding him turns
out Charles is about to undergo a
procedure to completely change his
facial appearance this is the 10th time
he is about to do so when the head
doctor inquires if he needs any
anesthesia to Bear the pain Charles
refuses stating that he likes pain he
wants to undergo the surgery in a
completely conscious State meanwhile
some cops have gathered outside the
building someone has tipped them off
about Charles's whereabouts and they are
here to storm the surgery room and
finally apprehend him but before they
start the mission the chief cop warns
everyone that Charles is a dangerous
assassin who is capable of killing
several men single-handedly it's erotic
Troublesome bloke and he knows how to
give him the beans you know I'm Shine a
what after a while they slowly make
their way to the 13th floor where the
surgery is about to take place
unfortunately for them Charles is well
prepared as soon as the cops enter the
room he finishes off the chief doctor
Dodges The Barrage of bullets and then
runs through the corridor Charles then
smashes through a glass window and jumps
out of the building and despite free
falling from the 13th floor he lands
perfectly without any injuries he is
even able to run at full speed as if
jumping from buildings is his Forte
however no matter how fast he runs the
cops have cars and they eventually
Corner him in this way the notorious
Charles Ryan is finally apprehended
after 15 years of elusiveness okay how
did he jump out of that building though
they better explain that the scene then
shifts to an airplane where a beautiful
flight attendant Marta is checking on
the passengers one by one everything
appears to be going smoothly when
suddenly a shady looking guy pulls out a
gun and takes her hostage he threatens
to kill her if his demands are not mad
in response Marta casually kicks him in
the leg egg giving a nearby passenger
enough time to take the gun away from
him after this everyone starts clapping
and it's finally revealed that the whole
thing was just a practice session to
train the flight attendants in
self-defense somehow I doubt the right
course of action is to kick the guy with
the gun in the leg on an airplane the
Shady looking guy is John cutter
decorated soldier and retired secret
service agent who is known for his tough
stance on high-level crimes after a
while the general manager of Atlantic
International Airlines Sly Del Vecchio
arrives and takes Jon away it appears as
if the two are good friends Sly asks him
to get back in the business and serve
the nation once again but John refuses
he mentions that he no longer wants to
risk his life for others nonetheless Sly
offers him a job as the head of the
counter-terrorism unit in Atlantic
International Airlines John thinks for a
while and finally accepts when he is
told that he only has to work twice a
month I thought my life was just about
getting kicked in the balls by hot
flight attendants but guess this will do
elsewhere Charles is escorted to his
cell where his attorney is waiting for
him the latter reveals that the
authorities are planning to take him to
California and execute him in the chair
the only way to avoid it is if Charles
pleads Insanity unfortunately the
notorious terrorist doesn't take the
suggestion in good terms and he bashes
the attorney against the table claiming
I am not in sign in the next scene we
see a shirtless John meditating and
reminiscing about his past the movie
then flashes back to a few years ago
where John and his late wife are
shopping in a convenience store suddenly
a robber arrives there and attempts to
steal money from the counter as a man of
integrity John tries to stop him but the
robber holds his wife hostage everyone
in the store backs away but despite this
the robber shoots the poor woman Jon
eventually kills him but when he returns
to check on his wife she is already dead
the incident traumatized him so much
that he quit his work as a special agent
and isolated himself for months in the
present John gets ready for his first
day at work he has to stay Anonymous and
guard a large lockhead airline with
almost 200 passengers on it John is
assigned to seat number 57 hence the
name of the movie coincidentally Charles
and two FBI agents also board the plane
indicating that the flight is heading
for California one of the flight
attendants is Marta while the other one
is a beautiful young girl named Sabrina
meanwhile a little boy sees Charles and
fires an imaginary Bullet at him in
response the cold-hearted killer
pretends to be dead however when he
shoots the boy back his cuffs are
revealed which alarms the passengers
nearby him they start wondering if the
flight is safe and Sabrina assures them
that there is nothing to worry about
after a while she calls a suspicious
looking staff in the lower deck and asks
him to send over this special service
the guy obliges and puts a metal
briefcase on the waiting tray at the
same time John who is annoyed by his
chatty seatmate gets up and heads to the
restroom to have some alone time once he
locks the door Sabrina retrieves the
content from the metal box and it turns
out to be a gun she then proceeds
towards the two unsuspecting FBI agents
and shoots them in the head much to
everyone's horror after Charles unlocks
his cuffs three of his goons emerge out
of their seats and threaten everyone to
remain silent here it is revealed that
Charles had everything planned all along
when he got to know that the agents were
escorting him in a commercial airline he
immediately hired some people to hijack
it in the next scene Charles heads to
the cockpit and shoots one of the Pilots
Dead to assert his dominance then he
announces over the radio that they are
going to change courses and that the
plane is officially hijacked however if
the passengers remain calm and obey his
orders no harm will come to them John
who is still in the restroom overhears
all of this and gets terrified he
somehow manages to get a hold of the
plane's onboard phone and explain the
situation to his friend Sly following
this he expertly subdues one of the
hijackers takes his gun and then uses
him as a shield to confront Charles the
latter also grabs Marta creating an
intense showdown between the two however
Charles soon lets go of the flight
attendant and shoots an innocent man to
prove his point he then fires a shot
towards Jon but it accidentally kills
one of his henchmen taking advantage of
the commotion John and Marta run away
from there enter the elevator and take
it all the way down to the cargo hold
there they come across the suspicious
looking guy from earlier and inquire if
he knows anything about the hijackers
the man pretends to be shocked but at an
opportune moment he whips out a knife
and tries attacking Jon the two then
engage in an intense duel and in the end
our protagonist manages to knock the bad
guy out with an impressive kick if only
he was that good at doing his taxes
after tying him up Marta and John head
to the avionics section of the plane
where the latter proposes that they dump
all the fuel and force an emergency
landing Marta strictly opposes the idea
as it could easily results in a crash
but when Jon explains that it is their
only way she allows him to proceed once
the fuel is almost empty the two head
towards the landing gear as it is the
best place to jump out of the plane
without sustaining many injuries
fortunately the plan works and when
Charles learns that they are running low
on fuel he requests the pilots to make
an emergency landing at the nearest
airport meanwhile at the Atlantic
International headquarters Sly into
superiors find out that the hijacked
plane is preparing to land at a small
airstrip in Lake Lucille Louisiana hence
without wasting any time Sly boards its
Shopper and heads to the location
elsewhere John and Marta are waiting for
the plane to land so that they can jump
out of it few moments later the plane
eventually comes to a halt but when the
two are about to jump one of the
hijackers ambushes them from behind Jon
is pushed out of the plane while Marta
is taken hostage once again two cops
arrive at the scene and immediately
arrest Jon despite his best attempts to
claim he was the head of security on the
plane doesn't change the fact that you
didn't do your taxes buddy as he is
being escorted away Charles makes
contact with the control tower and the
chief sheriff Mr Biggs answers him
Charles immediately makes his demands
clear that the play needs to be refueled
inside 10 minutes in return he promises
to release 100 passengers when the
sheriff refuses to accept the deal
Charles kills five passengers to make a
statement this terrifies Mr Biggs and he
finally gives the green light to refuel
the plane after a while Jon is brought
to the control tower and even Mr Biggs
thinks that he is one of the bad guys
his doubts are finally confirmed when
the cunning Charles calls him once again
and lies that Jon is one of his men who
escaped after betraying him hearing this
Mr Biggs orders his officers to lock
John in the basement but the latter
impressively fights them off grabs a
police motorcycle and heads to the
airstrip meanwhile after the plane is
refueled Charles releases 100 passengers
as promised however taking advantage of
the commotion he also sneaks out with a
suspicious looking guy and another man
the three then head to a nearby fair at
the control tower the FBI finally
arrives and asks Mr Big to give a full
report on the situation when the sheriff
mentions that they had beat up and
caught John cutter the head agent gets
angry and finally reveals that Jon is
one of them tax evasion be damned
elsewhere at the carnival Fair Charles
and his men are secretly tailed by Jon
who is still adamant on catching them
unfortunately his cover is blown and one
of the hijackers attempts to shoot him
but misses an innocent person takes the
bullet resulting in in full-blown chaos
meanwhile Jon climbs up a ferris wheel
and one of the hijackers follows him
there the two engage in a small tussle
which ends with the man being chucked
off the ferris wheel resulting in his
immediate death if only he were that
good at fighting off his taxes after
this Jon jumps onto the unsuspecting
Charles and eventually subdues him as
the FBI and the local officers take him
away Sly Del vachio also arrives and
congratulates his friend for
successfully tackling the terrorists
however little did they know that the
problem is far from over Charles
threatens the officers that if he isn't
let free his goons on the plane will
start killing the passengers one by one
and enraged Jon tries to negotiate with
him but to no avail so with no options
left the FBI and the other officials
decide to let Charles back onto the
plane however they have an idea they
will deploy snipers on top of a nearby
building and as soon as Charles and the
other hijackers appear in sight they
will be shot dead why not just kill
Charles in the first place his goons are
idiots they'll just give up if he's dead
John is ordered to lead the entire
mission in the next scene two FBI agents
lead Charles to the plane but as they
are about to enter the snipers start
shooting them instead it turns out that
the suspicious looking guy from earlier
has killed the original snipers and is
now gunning down all the FBI agents soon
a shootout between the hijackers and the
Agents ensues which results in several
deaths including that of the suspicious
looking guy the plane also starts
getting away but Jon is not going to
give up so easily he along with Sly gets
into Mr biggs's car and asks him to
chase the plane the idea is to grab hold
of the retractable landing gear and
enter the plane through that although
the stunt is an extremely dangerous one
it is a piece of cake for Mr cutter he
effortlessly clings onto the landing
gear like it's his daily bread and
butter once inside he goes to the cargo
hold and kills one of the hijackers then
he sneaks onto Sabrina from behind and
knocks her out now the only hijacker
left standing is the notorious Charles
himself British before confront however
Jon heads to the cockpit and asks the
passengers to change course and head
back to the likely seal airstrip after
this the final showdown begins despite
Jon being a trained fighter Charles
matches him stride for stride a stray
bullet in their fight shatters one of
the windows causing the loss of air
pressure in the plane the main door is
also blown out and Marta who is standing
just next to it is left hanging for dear
life fortunately John acts quickly and
takes Charles near the broken exit the
two of them exchanged some final blows
and in the end Jon prevails by kicking
the terrorist out of the plane with him
now dead the madness is finally over and
all the passengers celebrate by busting
out some cringe moves Jon then contacts
his superiors at the control tower and
informs them that he has taken down
Charles making them rejoice in happiness
in the final scene the plane finally
lands and all the passengers are
escorted to safety Jon who is fed up
with all the commotion and his taxes
doesn't even bother facing the reporters
and simply walks away with his new
girlfriend Marta the movie ends as Sly
talks to the reporters and proudly says
that he was in charge of the entire
operation subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching